super excited to talk with you about
this fantastic film
thank you hey i got a i got a question
okay is my action figure ever going to
make it in there
if once uh hot toys releases that we can
talk got it got it it's uh
yes okay noted
we'll come back to that next time
exactly i don't think it's out yet just
throwing that out yet now exactly um so
i am curious which of your friends and
family were most excited that you were
joining the mcu
oh man i got this buddy chris right
chris is
the biggest nerd
i have ever
met
every single marvel movie that comes out
he he watches the entire slate of marvel
movies again so so shanxi is the you
know there's the 25th
movie in the mcu
he watched the 24 other ones leading up
to and then you know even when black
widow came out he watched like the other
23 like this dude is is
dedicated and and he was also one of the
first people that i called to tell that
i had gotten the role and he was just
just witnessing
witnessing what whatever was going on
with me but through his eyes is just
it's so incredible it's something so
pure about that enthusiasm because it's
free of any of the pressures or the
responsibility or any of the bigger
questions it's just this like pure
unadulterated almost childlike joy
so um i definitely you know he was with
me on the premiere on the red carpet he
was just like like a 12 year old
in a candy shop like he was just having
the best time of his life and so shout
out to
shout out to my boy chris
because he's he's
the best
that that's awesome um i am curious when
you got the role how much did kevin
feige and the people at marvel tell you
the long-term plans for the character
and how much is it sort of just them
saying you trust us we got this
yeah i think it was trust us i think it
was trust us we more we think we got
this
um i think it's like i i you know i
don't necessarily even know that they
they knew at the time
um i know that everyone thinks of you
know marvel studios as this like
you know this like this like
opaque room of people who have planned
out 20 years in the future but i think i
really do think it's an ever-evolving
thing and a company that isn't afraid to
lean into spontaneity sometimes and and
quick changes and so um i really did
enjoy working with them i have no idea i
have no idea what plans they have for
the character past this movie but i can
say i mean i i could definitely say that
i hope i'm a part of them i'm confident
so i'm going to switch gears because i
am so excited for star wars visions
and i believe that you are providing a
voice or somewhat part of it am i wrong
yes
uh you are not wrong you are not wrong
right so what i have to ask you what
does it mean to not only be in the lead
of this marvel movie but also getting to
be a voice in star wars and what can you
tease about your episode
um well there i could say that they're
very very different jobs and one of them
i got shipped to australia for a year
and then had to endure a grueling
training process and then you know shot
uh you know on on a bus for a month
where i scraped and bumped nearly every
single bone in my body on every single
appendage inside that bus and on the
other i got to go into an
air-conditioned um room for like a few
hours and lay down some voices and then
got to go home so
very different in scale but um i mean i
think it was a call that i couldn't i
couldn't refuse they're like do you
wanna
do you wanna do some some anime dubbing
for star wars and i was like
yeah
it was the easiest decision i ever made
cannot wait i already got to go thank
you so much for your time and seriously
i hope it's a huge hit for you guys
thank you man thank you i really
appreciate it